is that britney spears conservatorship
yeah
let's get five suggestions we'll divide
you guys up into segments um and then
we'll
we'll drop a beat so uh what kind of
area around here what do you guys think
well i heard two at the same time so you
said diwali which is the indian festival
of light what did you say
are you surprised that i mean [ __ ] it's
[ __ ]
yeah who what was the thing the other
person said it was also diwali oh it was
also dwelling is it diwali now
no no no just very a seasoning
but that's okay cool so diwali um let's
come to
this menstruation thank you very much
love it yeah
which is not the indian festival of
light it's very different
i studied anthropology university and
actually wrote essays about how
menstruation in certain indian
communities leads to the death of women
by drowning because the waters rise and
they believe that if the women
menstruating touch the flood waters
demons will exit their body
and ruin the crops that is a true fact
[Applause]
is why in certain indian communities the
bed is in the kitchen so when the water
rises the woman can sit on the bed and
still perform duties in and about the
kitchen
because certain indian villages are
slightly backwards in feminism but
that's fine
i'm not gonna be cruel or criticize that
because there's more of you there are of
me both here and in india
so um okay well
i thought that was quite a good joke
you're like no i'm gonna ruin it by
saying there's only one
here okay so menstruation diwali let's
come
back in the room let's get a suggestion
for you guys
was that britney spears conservatorship
yeah
okay cool um middle of the room what do
you want to rap about
i misheard that what was it cuddling oh
that was really nice thank you
and front of the room what do you want
to wrap up
you've already had given a suggestion
but i don't mind that one
unless you guys want to metaphysical
paradox metaphysical paradox
okay um i just said that's too easy yeah
maybe for an indian
[ __ ] off and uh no that's so horribly
racist
it's even worse because we [ __ ]
ruined their country like
india was loads of awesome little
kingdoms and then we walked in like
hello may we have your tea
and everything you own good day it was
um just give me a brief definition of
the metaphysical paradox
you don't [ __ ] know right that's fine
okay to remind you
britney spears conservatorship cuddling
menstruation diwali
botulism and the metaphysical paradox
you might need to remind me because
that's a few more than i usually take
but uh
let's have some fun with this um red and
jeremy you're okay to lay down a sweet
beat
that'd be cool cool yeah this is gonna
be
a freestyle that's a wrap made up on the
spot based on tally on suggestions it's
not written
it's not prepared it's not rehearsed and
please do not worry you beautiful
beautiful people
it will not be anywhere near as
atrociously bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
british boy to be
it's gonna be good you're not with me on
this but that's fine
it's gonna be good man it's gonna be i
i'm setting it off like a festival
based round the lights not a menorah
like the jews do
i see the indians maybe the hindus none
of the sikhs now they're in the good
wara
i'm talking about shiva and krishna i'd
rather light a little candle dance
around with some pills
getting all the color on yeah i'm gonna
separate from that and move away what's
good blood
i talk about the menstruation that's
good blood you see it flowing free
you're like yeah going wild it's a
reminder you no need for a child they
all flow i'm not new to this happens
every 28 days the uterus i know your
cycles might vary from short to long
fit the menstruation in this song and
we're coming on strong yeah
light light through a prism let me break
it down like i've got bacterial botulism
it's like a food poisoning like
salmonella but
more resonating in your tummy you're
feeling very funny and you're off to
visit the gp go and check that doctor
and say
stop doctor i feel beat down why cause i
let some raw meat down
it doesn't matter though i never let
myself get in the model relax upon the
bed i asked my wife to cuddle she like
ah
this is really nice i love to cuddle up
to my lady at night and if i wanna go
one step further
and get a kind of sexual fervor she says
now chris just cuddling that's enough
why cause menstruation is the time of
the month i'm not saying
you can't go what comes next you can't
get involved with the period sex
it's a problem yeah and i'm offering
this i try and break down the physics
hypothesis
you're like it's a paradox so there's no
answer metaphysical my man in the long
pants there was like i don't [ __ ]
know what it even means i just shouted
out whoa and the crowd screams
and the last one i know all of y'all are
with me we can chant as one [ __ ] free
britney
you gotta make sure jamie spears gets
out of the
court and he's out of here he's a weird
looking dude taking all of her money i
know she went a bit while brain went a
bit funny
but still we can play it loud hear the
bop hit everybody loves baby one more
time and toxic britney
yeah it's a shame that you're not on
stage gigging in vegas i saw the
documentary and i was like i'll make a
plaque card and stand outside the court
in l.a and i march hard
let a free other conservative ship come
on britney we know you can steer the
ship and say it right so there we go
freestyle spitting me
and as we said before free [ __ ]
[Applause]
britney
you